If you are in that community,
good fucking luck getting out.
Right.
Good luck.
The,
the money that you get other than Welfare's from selling pills,
you know,
everybody's on these pills so you're all whacked out.
You don't know what the fuck is going on.
Half the day you're on opiates.
I mean,
it is a bananas environment and there's a lot of people like that in this
country and in poor Latino communities and poor white communities in poor black
communities.
The idea that these people are just going to pull themselves up by their
bootstraps,
it's crazy.
I just think they don't have a plan.
And I think if we really want to help them there,
there's gotta be some way where you can give these people the opportunity to
step out of that pattern,
whatever that community centers,
outreach programs,
whatever it is.
I don't know what
I mean.
The truth is,
the truth is that historically speaking,
it was people actually going to church.
Yeah.
I mean,
and,
and yeah,
there's a good lot of good PR church going person.
Right,
right.
Absolutely.
Recognize that there's a lot of good involved and having that framework
right.
And,
and that,
that,
I'm not sure that that's,
I don't think you can create sort of a fake social fabric with just a government
welfare system.
Like it just,
it does,
it hasn't worked.
I mean,
disability exists.
I'd been increasing every year.
It's,
it's not this,
it's a question I asked Andrew getting,
actually,
sorry.
Our episode comes out on Sunday and obviously Andrew is a big fan of the ubi,
universal basic income.
And I'm not averse to the idea of ubi in a future where legitimately 50% of the
population can't work because they've all been automated out of existence and
all of this.
But there's one section in his book where Andrea talks about how if we cut
people a check for ubi,
then they will spend their extra time creating art and engaging in hobbies that
they like.
And I just thought to myself,
I'm mean,
set it to him like people are on disability at it,
what they're doing right.
And if you're on disability,
the people you're talking about who are suffering,
they're not out there writing poetry.
Right.
I mean the,
the,
the rise of the opioid epidemic and people who are oding on drugs and and all
this stuff that's in precisely the same demographic you're talking about.
You're just talking about a check from one place as opposed to another place.
I don't,
I don't really see how that solves the problem.
I think we have a crisis of purpose.
Yes.
Right now and I don't think that that crisis is purpose is solvable on the one
hand by changing our trade rules and I also don't think that that crisis is a
purpose is solvable by by cutting a government check.
I just don't think that that's how people are wired.
I absolutely agree with you that there is a crisis of purpose.
My concern is about automation and my concern,
and obviously I haven't really studied this other than talking to Andrew Yang
and talking to Ilan mosque and a few other people that are proponents of
universal basic income,
they think that there's going to be such a massive loss of jobs in such a short
period of time from people that are non skilled laborers and it's going to go
away.
There's millions and millions of jobs and these people are not gonna have
anything and that it could be chaos,
right?
So there's,
there's two problems that come up there and this is where Andrew's book is
interesting because problem number one is that the people will be poor.
They won't have a source of income.
Yeah,
you'll be ice,
all of that.
The other part of it,
but does it even that gives him $1,000 a month
if he opted,
right.
I mean,
even even if you just had a Swedish redistribution system and,
and the average tax rate went up to 60% or something,
it might let,
let's say we could solve the money problem for a second,
which,
you know,
without tanking the economy,
which is questionable,
but let's say we could do that.
We could add trillions of dollars to the budget every year,
and we could tell that I'm still not sure that that solves the deeper problem,
which is that when people lose jobs,
they lose purpose,
right?
So I'm not sure that UBI solves that problem.
As I say,
we have,
we have a rich social welfare network in the United States and we're seeing this
stuff happen anyway.
You know,
I'm,
I'm a little bit,
I'm a little bit less catastrophic by a little bit,
I mean,
a fair bit less catastrophic in my thinking about automation than,
than either Andrew Yang or Elon Musk will be able to adapt quick enough to avoid
the problems.
They'll realize the jobs aren't there any more,
and they'll just naturally gravitate towards other professionals.
I think over time that people will do that,
but they're not always the same people or there's always shifts in the economy
and the ideal economic model has a truck or becoming a coder.
Right.
But that's,
that's not real.
That was the whole learn to code fiasco.
People ticked off of Twitter.
Right,
and it still,
yeah,
apparently if you say to journalists,
then that's,
that's very bad.
If you say,
let's go to a truck.
Yeah,
that's what it was.
[inaudible] to code to a trucker.
If you say learn to code to a trucker,
then that's just you being helpful.
If you say learn to code to a journalist,
then that is targeted harassment on Twitter.
That's where that starts is to me,
well I meant were Twitter doesn't care about you.
I can say whatever I want,
but it's a,
but yeah,
I mean I think that,
but if you just say it to a friend,
hey,
fuck face,
learn to code.
They that,
I don't know,
it's your friend could report you to the censorship board over at Twitter.
It's such a dumb thing to take people out for it.
It's one of the best examples of like how censorship oversteps its boundaries
and becomes almost like satire.
Yeah.
It's,
it's real.
It's really,
really absurd.
This is the biggest aggression ever.
Learn to code.
That's something,
look,
this is a stupid thing that someone said about coal miners.
They readily said that about coal miners that maybe they can learn to code and
so every like what?
Fuck,
and so learn to code became a joke and became something that you would mock
people,
right there is their explanation for it was so crazy.
It was like,
no.
Then learn to code got connected with white supremacists and all this other
stuff.
That's the Hitler owned a dog.
They recommend,
right?
Dogs are bad.
Hitler owned one.
Okay,
white supremacists are bad.
They used the phrase,
learn to code.
That means if you say learn to code,
you're a white supremacist.
Like what?
Tommy lost the frog.
That fucking frog feels good,
man.
Frog.
That's what happened to pepe.
They lie.
They killed the frog.
They turned the front frog gay.
I mean,
what?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I mean it's hot as far as automation.
Um,
you know,
there's constantly people saying this is the,
the Nicholas Nassim tell lead view of reality,
which that the Black Swan incident can happen any any second.
So watch out for it.
Versus the sort of Steven pinker view of reality,
which is the black swan incident is called the black swan incident because it's
a black swan incident,
meaning that it happens incredibly rarely the,
the idea that we are on the verge of a catastrophic drop in job numbers because
of the automation of trucking for example.
I'm not sure that I buy it.
The reason I don't buy it is because you still are gonna need someone sitting
behind the wheel of that truck there human drivers on the road.
Uh,
it's going to,
there will be a gradual transition away from some of these jobs with the Andrew
getting talks about radiologists and how radiologists are going to be priced out
of the market by computers that can do a better job of diagnosing tumors,
first of all.
Awesome.
Right?
I mean,
that's,
that's good.
First of all that brings down cost and you won't get cancer is advanced.
That'd be,
that'd be a good thing.
And then second of all,
what,
what a lot of technology studies have had attended to show is that technology
just gets integrated into different Wagan in particular careers.
So there will be jobs that are eliminated for sure.
There'll be jobs we haven't heard of that will be created also.
And mostly technology will will become more of a productivity aid to to people.
So this is true in factories.
Jobs have been lost in factories.
It's the best example of our jobs are lost,
but it's mostly true and offices,
right?
How many office jobs had been created because you have computers?
What's more office jobs exist because I write by hand.
Do you think that this is akin to like a government bailout?
Like the idea of the government bailout was like the banks are too big to fail
and some people thought,
you know what,
you got to let them fail so you figure out why they failed and we'll never have
it happen again.
If there is this thing and the government steps in and says,
wait a minute,
I know you lost all your jobs,
we're going to give you $1,000.
You don't have to figure it out $1,000 a month.
And some people go,
okay,
I'm not going to figure it out now.
Whereas those people might have gone on a fear filled journey to try to figure
out their purpose in life because now they're stuck.
They're stuck where their job doesn't exist anymore.
So there
what are their owner?
I mean they have to act.
There is,
there is an innovation that comes from,
from a welfare check.
I mean there are people who become dependent on government than they're used to
being dependent on government.
That that stuff is true.
It does happen.
And listen,
Milton Friedman made an argument for universal basic income as a replacement for
the welfare system.
There is another problem with universal basic income that I asked Andrew about
also.
And that was one of the,
one of the big issues is that poor people,
very often people who are permanently impoverished,
not people who are temporarily poor,
but they tend not to spend money where we think they ought to spend money,
right?
They're not taking that money and they're not putting it into education or into
the marches and Ho hos and cigarettes.
The,
the average,
the average person who is making less than,
I think it was $16,000 a year,
we're spending $400 here in lottery tickets.
Right?
But it's legitimately just flushing your money down the toilet.
So it's so how do you,
aren't you just going to end up back in the same place you could in six months
where people took that money and used it in ways that actually didn't benefit
them.
And at a certain point,
the question is,
are your,
do you own your decisions?
You do not own your decisions.
And at what level of incompetence or inability do we say you no longer own your
decisions and so we're just going to take care of you on a permanent basis.
That's,
that's really the,
the,
the question here.
Yeah.
Uh,
when you're talking about welfare,
we're looking at worst case scenario,
right?
Where someone does get dependent upon the welfare state and does use that money
frivolously and does make poor decisions.
But then there's gotta be other people that are single moms that,
you know,
maybe had a kid with some fucking asshole that doesn't want to pay.
It was a piece of shit and they have to hide from them and they're just trying
to feed their kids.
Yeah.
For sure.
Those people exist to have a community to do,
to help them out and maybe they're not a part of a church,
then maybe they don't have a good group of neighbors.
Maybe they had to move somewhere for work and they got stuck in some place where
they don't know anybody.
But it,
I,
I think part of this is to recognize that incentives matter on both ends.
So the idea is that you give some people more money and they'll,
they'll do well.
It's also true that if you create a welfare system that benefits single
motherhood,
you will get more single motherhood.
I mean the,
the single mother had written the black community before wealth,
there was 20% now it's 70% in the white community was like 5% now it's 40%
you've said that like
out of wedlock children and having a kid when you're young is like,
it's a terrible idea for your life,
but what do you recommend to have kids avoid that?
Are you one of those people
don't add up there without that thing on it?
No condoms is what you're saying,
right?
Like don't,
don't,
don't have unprotected sex.
I mean like this,
this is not,
it's not part of my,
but my fake cursing.
It's not anything rocket science.
I mean like apologizing for not courteous and apologetic or not cursing.
It's not rocket science.
It's one of the holy fathers.
Kids make mistakes yet.
I mean that's what happens.
People get thrown it.
But,
and then if the government pays for those mistakes,
it becomes less.
So what should,
what should happen?
Should the kids suffer?
So the who no,
I mean presumption it be any actually be worked out.
I mean it depends on the situation.
If there are parents available to the kid,
presumably the parents,
the grandparents would take a pretty active role in the,
in the raising the kid.
I'll assume that they're there.
Well,
I,
how about this?
How about we assume that if you are old enough to get pregnant,
then you are old enough to l let's,
let's talk about a 17 year old or 18 year old.
Used to be shotgun marriages,
a thing and uh,
and really like that's a good idea.
I think the idea of parents staying together for the sake of a kid,
did they accidentally is absolutely a good idea.
Yes.
I think that,
I think that is a better idea than the man walking away and the kid being
without a man in the house.
So you're saying that their childhood panels figure a way to work it out?
Yes.
And if they were both reasonable,
they could do that.